[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
keine Krise ohne MPK wir erinnern uns ja
noch an die berüchtigten Bund Länder
Marathon Sitzung zu den corona-maßnahmen
bis tiefen die Nacht ging es diesmal
nicht was vielleicht auch daran lag dass
es heute noch nicht so viel Konkretes zu
entscheiden gab es nicht dass die Zeit
nicht drängen würde der Winter steht ja
nicht mehr vor der Tür er ist mit einem
Fuß schon drinnen die Heizsaison hat
begonnen da sollte doch langsam klar
werden wie sich die Bundesregierung ihre
gaspreisbremse vorstellt dann Treffen
des Bundeskanzlers mit den
Ministerpräsidenten und Präsidentinnen
ging es aber auch noch um eine Reihe
weiterer Themen und vor allem darum wer
welche Kosten trägt aus Berlin Britta
Spickermann
große Runde im Kanzleramt heute am
Nachmittag die gute Stimmung dürfte für
Kameras wohl eher gespielt sein
schließlich gab es erhebliche
Verstimmungen zwischen Bund und Ländern
entlastungspakete Abwehrschirm wer zahlt
was und wo kommt das Geld an viele
Fragezeichen
Abwehr Schirm 200 Milliarden das ist
bekannt was die Auswirkung angeht ist
das noch ein bisschen eine Wundertüte
keiner weiß genau was drin ist aber alle
freuen sich schon mal
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident weil
dem am kommenden Sonntag eine Wahl ins
Haus steht spricht schon vorab nur von
einem möglichen Zwischenstand die
Erwartung meines Erachtens sollten an
konkrete Ergebnisse nicht zu hoch
gehängt werden um viertel nach Neun am
Abend dann das Ende der Konferenz fast
überraschend früh und ganz
offensichtlich ist die Verstimmung
geblieben nichts Konkretes ich habe den
Eindruck dass wir davon sehr
konstruktiven Pfad unterwegs sind und
uns auch miteinander über diese Aufgabe
verständigen werden auch die Länder
haben sehr genau gesehen wie groß der
Beitrag des Bundes in jedem Fall sein
wird mit 240 und 250 Milliarden Euro von
den insgesamt 295 Milliarden die da als
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger fließen
weiter dezent beim Wohngeld der Bund
will es ausweiten dann solle das
Wohngeld aber auch in Zukunft komplett
bezahlen sagen die Länder mit den
Flüchtlingszahlen steigen auch die
Kosten die Länder sehen den Bund stärker
in der Pflicht
öffentlicher Personennahverkehr
zwischendurch wurde es eng beim 9 Euro
Ticket ein Nachfolgemodell soll kommen
aber eben unter anderem Bedingungen
wir sind bereit und wollen auch einen
Anschlussticket auch mitfinanzieren
seinen Länder aber wir müssen unbedingt
auch darüber sprechen wie geht es weiter
mit den Regionalisierungsmitteln die im
übrigen ja auch ein Koalitionsvertrag
vorgesehen sind das heißt die Länder
verlangen von Bund mehr Mittel für Züge
und Infrastruktur große Not melden die
Kliniken in der Energiekrise Minister
Lauterbach hat Hilfen versprochen wie
sie konkret aussehen ist
Verhandlungsmasse die größte
Herausforderung ist und bleibt er von
Bundeskanzler Scholz sogenannte
doppelwumms der 200 Milliarden Euro
Abwehrschirm um Energiekosten für
Bevölkerung und Wirtschaft zu deckeln
Finanzminister Lindner glaubt immer noch
die Schuldenbremse nächstes Jahr wieder
einhalten zu können andere fragen sich
ob den Worten noch wirklich Taten folgen
es darf aus seinem Bums kein wümchen
werden sondern es muss jetzt endlich
gehandelt werden und es ist die Aufgabe
der Regierung wie die Regierung diese
Aufgabe lösen will soll eine bereits
eingesetzte Kommission erarbeiten auf
Druck der Länder und der Wirtschaft
jetzt schneller als geplant
parallel dazu arbeitet die gaskommission
die wir gebeten haben die Arbeit
vorzuziehen jedenfalls die Empfehlung
für eine gaspreisbremse vorzuziehen also
nicht Ende Oktober erst sondern
möglichst Anfang Oktober schon nächstes
Treffen wahrscheinlich erst Ende Oktober
wahrscheinlich erst nach der
Steuerschätzung Fazit es bleibt
Irritation man muss sich wohl erst noch
einmal sortieren
ja und eine die dabei war ist Anke
Rehlinger die SPD Ministerpräsidentin
des Saarlands guten Abend Frau Rehlinger
schönen guten Abend Frau slonka haben
sie einen langen Tag in Berlin verbracht
wenn sie jetzt nach Hause fahren und da
eigentlich nicht viel Konkretes heute
bei rumgekommen ist ist das nicht
irgendwie unbefriedigend
ich finde schon dass wir heute noch mal
einen wichtigen Punkt gemacht haben vor
allem für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
eben den deutlich geworden ist dass alle
anerkennen dass der Bund tatsächlich ein
großes Paket auf den Tisch gelegt hat
dass geeignet ist den Anstieg der Preise
sowohl beim Strom als auch beim Gas zu
bremsen und das finde ich ist schon ein
wichtiges Signal dass wir dann auf der
Wegstrecke noch ein Miteinander ein
bisschen darüber diskutieren wie wir
diese Lasten auf unseren breiten
Schultern dann verteilen wollen das ist
nicht entscheidend für das was am Ende
bei den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
rauskommt insofern kann ich zumindest im
Saarland schon mal sagen der Bund hat
erkannt das muss gehandelt werden und es
wird auch Gehandelt dieses Signal dass
das gab es ja schon vorher aber es
bleibt eine Wundertüte wie der
nordrhein-westfälische Ministerpräsident
sagt und wie diese Wundertüte nun was da
drin ist weiß man immer noch nicht weil
der Tag jetzt erstmal eine Kommission
ja der Umstand ist ein bisschen den
Zeitabläufen geschuldet die Kommission
ist eingesetzt die hat sich bereits
einmal getroffen und wird am Wochenende
auch noch mal sehr intensiv tagen und
wir haben heute so ein bisschen ja den
strukturellen Mangel gehabt dass
natürlich die Frage was man noch tun
muss und was vielleicht sogar in der ein
oder anderen Stelle auch wegfallen kann
an Hilfen und Unterstützungen nicht
beantwortet werden kann ohne zu wissen
wie diese konkrete Ausgestaltung denn
erfolgen wird insofern müssen wir das
Abwarten deshalb ist es auch richtig zu
sagen wir treffen uns noch mal und
daraus Fachebene werden die Fragen bei
denen wir uns noch nicht ganz einig sind
noch mal intensiv miteinander beraten
werden dazu gehört das Thema Wohngeld
dazu gehört die Frage der
flüchtlingskosten aber eben auch
Regionalisierungsmittel und damit das
Nachfolgemodell für das 9 euro-ticket
strukturrecker struktureller Mangel ist
ein bisschen schöner Begriff in den
merke ich mir man redet über etwas ohne
überhaupt zu wissen was am Ende dabei
herauskommen wird sie ganz konkret haben
sie aber das Wohngeld geredet sie
wollten gerne dass der Bund also sie die
Länder da waren alle recht einig über
die Parteigrenzen hinweg wollten dass
der Bund das künftig komplett übernimmt
aber da hat Herr Scholz ja offenkundig
gesagt kommt nicht in Frage
naja ich muss einfach sagen wir befinden
uns jetzt auch ein Stück weit in einer
Verhandlungssituation mit dem Bund und
da ist es jetzt auch sehr natürlich dass
die Länder die auch miteinander
vorbereiten haben erstmal ihre Position
formulieren der Bund der Bundeskanzler
formuliert die eigene Position und jetzt
ist die Aufgabe in den nächsten Tagen
und Wochen viel länger würde sicherlich
gar nicht in Anspruch nehmen zu gucken
wie wir zusammenkommen welche Kosten wir
fair auf den Schultern von wem
letztendlich auch verteilen beim
Wohngeld ist es nun mal so dass es schon
eine sozialausgabe darstellt ob das
jetzt komplett übernommen werden kann
das gilt es sicherlich auch in einem
Gesamtpaket zu beraten die
Regionalisierungsmittel ich habe es eben
gesagt ist der nächste Punkt das wäre
ein Durchbruch ein bundesweites
öpnv-ticket zu haben aber am Ende muss
das Gesamtpaket auch im ÖPNV stimmen
denn Verkehre abzubestellen quasi
gleichzeitig das kann auch nicht im
Interesse des Bundes sein und die Dinge
gilt es jetzt einfach gut miteinander zu
beraten für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
da ist wichtig dass dadurch nichts
aufgehalten wird das ist glaube ich die
wichtige oder die werden das sauber
miteinander besprechen da hat aber ja
heute auch rum kam ja auch ein klares
Signal also mehr als diese 1,5
Milliarden die die der
Bundesfinanzminister schon zugesagt hat
dass sie Regionalisierung wir sprechen
jetzt über den wenn Nachfolger eines
billig Tickets wie billig ist dann auch
immer sein wird da wollten die Länder ja
viel mehr an Unterstützung für den
Nahverkehr das wird aber wohl nicht
kommen oder meinen Sie da bewegt sich
jetzt auf Seiten der Bundesregierung
noch ganz viel
naja ich bin zunächst mal zuversichtlich
dass auch die Kraft der Argumente
sicherlich sich noch entfalten wird
insbesondere auch beim ÖPNV denn beim
Verkehr wir können den nicht abbestellen
wir werden die klimastiele nicht
erreichen können wenn wir die
mobilitätswende nicht schaffen und da
hilft ein einziges Produkt ein sehr
attraktives nicht aus einige Länder
stehen jetzt schon vor der Frage
Verkehre abzubestellen und dann sind wir
an dem Punkt angelangt wo man sagen muss
für einige wird es toll es wird günstig
aber was nützt diejenigen bei denen gar
kein Bus vor der Haustür mehr vorbei
fährt das kann niemand wollen deshalb
müssen wir ernsthaft diese Frage aber
eben auch noch ein paar andere
miteinander diskutieren Frau Rehlingen
danke für das Gespräch heute Abend
direkt nach dieser bundländerrunde
herzlichen Dank
ja wenn Bund und Länder an einem Tisch
sitzen ist das natürlich eine nationale
Diskussion wie hierzulande die Kosten
verteilt werden wer welche Hilfen
braucht und wo wir genug gasher bekommen
was dabei ein wenig aus dem Blickfeld
gerät Deutschland ist keine Insel was
wir tun wirtschaftlich hat natürlich
Auswirkungen auf andere europäische
Länder der deutsche doppelwumms kommt in
Europa jedenfalls nicht überall gut an
Tenor erst profitieren die deutschen
jahrelang von billigen großen Gas und
jetzt wo sie sprichwörtlich in die Röhre
gucken jagen sie mit ihren Einkäufen für
uns alle die Preise hoch und der
deutsche Alleingang bei der
gaspreisbremse der könne zu
Wettbewerbsverzerrungen führen so der
Vorwurf Bundesfinanzminister Lindner
musste sich beim Treffen heute mit
seinen europäischen Kollegen jedenfalls
einige Fragen anhören Florian Neuhann
berichtet
als Klaus Ricklingen 2010 erstmals in so
einen Dienstwagen steigt geht es ums
Überleben einer Währung des Euro 12
Jahre später geht der Chef des
Euro-Rettungsschirms in Rente und es
geht selbst in den nüchternen Worten
eines EU-Beamten um mehr
bewegen uns in eine Wirtschaftskrise
hinein
aufgrund der hohen Energiepreise Energie
Knappheit das führt zu hohen Inflation
zu Kaufkraftverlust es wird zu mehr
Insolvenzen kommen in allen europäischen
Ländern das ist ja kein deutsches
Problem aber Deutschland ist natürlich
besonders betroffen es ist Regel links
letzte Sitzung mit den Finanzministern
es ist eine in der Deutschland besonders
betroffen ist von Kritik aus ganz Europa
das deutsche Entlastungspaket ein
Alleingang und solidarisch so heißt es
der Finanzminister muss sich wortreich
erklären alles angeblich nur ein
Missverständnis auch seitens der
Europäischen Kommission
auch nicht vollständig erkannt dass es
nicht um eine Maßnahme geht für das Jahr
2022 sondern dass sie auch den Zeitraum
2023 und 24 umfasst ob die Erklärung
verfängt immerhin gehen zwei
EU-Kommissare heute noch weiter fordern
gemeinsame europäische Schulden zur
Finanzierung auch dieser Krise wie schon
in der corona-pandemie
wenn wir diese Krise bewältigen wollen
dann brauchen wir ein höheres Maß an
Solidarität
wieder muss Lindner abwehren er will
keinen neuen europäischen Schulden der
deutsche Euro-Retter reklam sieht das
später im ZDF-Interview übrigens ein
wenig anders
das kann sinnvoll sein je nachdem wie
sich die Wirtschaftslage entwickeln aber
Moment ist die Diskussion darüber sehr
kontrovers neue eu-schulden wohl ohne
Bedingungen es wäre der endgültige
Abschied vom Grundprinzip des Euro
Rettungsschirms der vergab Kredite nur
gegen Reformen und war dabei für die
Steuerzahler bisher keinen Verlust die
Kredite kommen ja zurück irgendwann
bei Griechenland ist die letzte
Rückzahlung erst im Jahre 2017 also in
fast 50 Jahren
die Lebenserwartung steigt ja immer aber
ich werde das nicht als Mitarbeiter des
ESM erleben am Freitag räumt Klaus
Rickling 72 sein Büro auf einen
Nachfolge konnten sich die
Finanzminister bisher nicht einigen
dabei wäre dieser Streit vielleicht
leichter zu lösen als der ums Geld
immerhin der eigentliche Verursacher all
dieser Turbulenzen Wladimir
vladimirowitsch Putin hatte heute erneut
keinen guten Tag es ist gerade zu
atemberaubend zu beobachten in welchem
Tempo die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
vorrücken fast stündlich werden neue
Ortschaften gemeldet aus denen die
russischen Besatzer vertrieben wurden
inzwischen scheint es sogar möglich dass
die Ukraine die wichtige Hafenstadt
zurückerobert das wäre für Putin ein
weiterer Schlag den er zu Hause
eigentlich kaum erklären kann daran
Hassan sadi gibt einen Überblick über
das aktuelle Kriegsgeschehen
es sind selbstgedrehte Aufnahmen von
ukrainischen Soldaten die in der Region
herson kämpfen Dorf nach Dorf wurde von
den russischen Besatzern befreit doch
für den einzelnen Soldaten kann auch
eine erfolgreiche Offensive den Tod
bedeuten eine russische aufklärungskrone
am Himmel es bleibt nur wenig Zeit um
ihr und der russischen Artillerie zu
entkommen
ein befreites Dorf in der Region herson
den Einwohnern sind die Leiden der
russischen Besatzung ins Gesicht
geschrieben
in nur einer Woche konnte die Ukraine 40
Kilometer lang zurückerobern gebietet
die Putin offiziell gerade annektiert
hat
die Wirkung dieser Kampfhandlungen ist
offensichtlich mehr und mehr russische
Einheiten flüchten der Feind erleidet
mehr und mehr Verluste und es gibt eine
wachsende Einsicht das Russland einen
Fehler gemacht hat den Krieg gegen die
Ukraine zu beginnen
limane im Nordosten der Ukraine die
Schäden des Krieges auch seelische
siegreiche ukrainische Soldaten sie
bergen ihre gefallenen Kameraden
wir kämpfen für unser Land für unsere
Kinder damit unser Volk besser leben
kann aber all das hat einen sehr hohen
Preis
Liman eine Kleinstadt mit ehemals 20.000
Einwohnern jetzt ohne Gas und Strom aus
fünf Backsteinen und einer Glut haben
sie hier ihren Herd gebaut sie sind
entbehrungsreich die ersten Tage der
Freiheit in Liman
das Putin wohl tatsächlich dachte sein
riesiges Nachbarland einen der größten
Flächenstaaten Europas im Handstreiche
obern zu können ist schon jetzt eine
Fehleinschätzung historischen Ausmaßes
die Frage ist ob er noch weiteren
Fehleinschätzungen unterliegen wird etwa
zu glauben dass in der Einsatz von
Atomwaffen einem Sieg näher bringen
könnten schlimm genug dass auf
ukrainischen Boden rund um
Atomkraftwerke gekämpft wird
Kamera hat Raphael grossi getroffen den
Mann dessen Job es ist die nuklearen
Risiken dieses Krieges nach Möglichkeit
zu begrenzen
er bezeichnet sich selbst als nuklearen
Wachhund Raphael grossi Chef der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde hier
vor Ort im größten Atomkraftwerk Europas
in saporicia der Argentinier ist derzeit
ein gefragter Krisenmanager uns empfängt
der in seiner Schaltzentrale in Wien
von hier aus beobachtet er die
Konfliktherde der Welt an der
Freilassung des Direktors der Atomanlage
in saporicia war er beteiligt erzählt er
uns die Drohungen eines atomschlages
durch Putin bereiten im große Sorgen
politische Rhetorik natürlich von der
Realität trennen
aber was wir sehen ist ein negativer
Trend eine Art Banalisierung von
Nuklearwaffen
als ob sie eine ernsthafte Alternative
wären die man nutzen könnte ein
nuklearer Angriff wäre eine furchtbar
schlimme Sache ich hoffe das wird nie
passieren
und auch die Gefahr eines nuklearen
Unfalls bleibt wie der mehrfache
Beschuss des umkämpften Atomkraftwerks
in saporichia gezeigt hat die Lage sei
außer Kontrolle sagte grossy vor wenigen
Wochen inzwischen sind Experten der
Atomenergiebehörde vor Ort doch die
Gefahr sei unverändert hoch so krossi
es ist eine Tatsache dass die größte
Nuklearanlage Europas täglich beschossen
wird das ist doch irre können Sie sich
so etwas in Deutschland vorstellen wo
sie auch Nuklearanlagen haben auch
stillgelegte Anlagen werden beschossen
es ist total absurd ich habe riesige
Löcher auf dem Dach eine Halle gesehen
die frisches Nuklearmaterial enthielt
daher arbeite ich an der Umsetzung einer
sofortigen Schutzzone rund um das
Kraftwerk
protection
diese Woche noch will grossi in Kiew von
in Moskau vorsprechen um die Schutzzone
durchzusetzen doch er hat noch andere
Baustellen wie den atomdeal mit Iran
rossi hat vor wenigen Tagen den
Gesprächsfaden mit Teheran wieder
aufgenommen doch Iran hat uran-partikel
nicht deklariert und 27 kontrollkameras
der Atomenergiebehörde abgebaut ist der
atomdeal so noch zu retten
und hatte Iran die Bombe
sehr hoch an bis zu 60 Prozent 90%
reichen für eine Atomwaffe der Iran ist
nah dran daher sage ich der atomdeel ist
in einem sehr brüchigen Zustand ob tot
oder lebendig das sollen andere
beurteilen
Raphael grossi ein wichtiger Vermittler
seine Rolle wird in diesen Zeiten
dringend gebraucht
ob sich der Westen von den nuklearen
Drohungen Russlands erpressen lässt wird
jedenfalls auch in anderen Weltregionen
sehr genau beobachtet einer dessen macht
praktisch komplett auf der Bombe beruht
und das heute mal wieder nachdrücklich
demonstriert damit wir die Nachrichten
Hals der erneut hat Nordkorea eine
ballistische Mittelstreckenrakete in
Richtung japanisches Meer abgeschossen
und erst mal seit fünf Jahren flog sie
direkt über Japan Japans Regierungschef
kishida bezeichnete den Vorfall als
Gewaltakt die USA und Südkorea reagiert
mit einer gemeinsamen Militärübung auf
den Vorfall dabei erprobten sie
satellitengesteuerte präzisionsbomben
die USA wollen eine Sitzung zu dem
erneuten Raketentest im
UN-Sicherheitsrat beantragen
Außenministerin baerbock hat die Opfer
des Warschauer Aufstandes gegen die
deutschen Besatzer von 1944 gewürdigt
sie legte zum Abschluss Ihres Besuches
in der polnischen Hauptstadt auf dem
Friedhof für die Aufständischen einen
Kranz nieder zuvor hatte Borg bei einem
Gespräch mit Ihrem polnischen
Amtskollegen rau
Reparationsforderungen zurückgewiesen
Deutschland
steht ohne wenn und aber zugleich ist
die Frage nach Reparationen aus Sicht
der Bundesregierung das weißt Du
abgeschlossen
US-Präsident beiden hat Sanktionen gegen
Verantwortliche in iranen aus sich
gestellt die Gewalt gegen friedliche
Demonstranten einsetzen die Proteste in
Iran gehen weiter heute
unterrichtsboykott der Studentinnen und
Studenten an der Technischen Universität
Teheran draußen bezog bewaffnete
bereitschaftspolizeilstellung
Präsident reisi bekräftigte im Parlament
dass die Proteste von Amerika und Israel
gesteuert wurden
in Deutschland ist unter den jüngeren
Menschen der Anteil mit einem hohen
Bildungsabschluss gestiegen zu diesem
Ergebnis kommt die Organisation für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung OECD in ihrem
Bildungsbericht demnach hatten 2021 in
Deutschland 36 Prozent der 25 bis
34-Jährigen einen Abschluss etwa an
einer Universität Fachhochschule oder
als Meister im Handwerk im Jahr 2000
waren es noch
22%. allerdings sei zuletzt auch der
Anteil derjenigen gestiegen die ohne
Ausbildung und Arbeit dastehen
der Nobelpreis für Physik geht in diesem
Jahr an drei Wissenschaftler für ihre
Forschungen im Bereich der winzigsten
Teilchen der Quantenmechanik die
Schwedische Akademie gab die
Auszeichnung für den Franzosen Allah ASB
den US-Amerikaner John Kloser und den
Österreicher anton Zeilinger bekannt sie
hätten bahnbrechende Experimente mit
verschränkten Quantenzuständen
durchgeführt bei denen sich Teilchen wie
eine Einheit Verhalten auch wenn sie
getrennt und weit voneinander entfernt
sind inzwischen wird damit der neuen
Computer-
dass man in dem Moment wo man
Regierungsverantwortung übernimmt
Kompromisse machen muss dürfte jeder
Partei klar sein
Koalitionspartner und die schiere Macht
des Faktischen führen immer dazu dass
man Teile seines Wahlprogramms still und
leise in der Schublade verschwinden
lässt wenn dann aber auch noch
historische Krisen hinzukommen wie erst
Corona und jetzt der Krieg wird es für
alle Beteiligten richtig bitter der
grüne Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck
etwa hatte bei Amtsantritt sicher nicht
die Vision dass er Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen lässt oder klimaschädliche Kohle
aus der Reserve holt übel sind auch die
Entscheidungen die die Grünen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen jetzt mittragen dort
müssen sie sich von Umweltschützern
Verrat vorwerfen lassen dort Färber
berichtet
das ist lützerath für die
Umweltaktivisten das Dorf im rheinischen
Braunkohle Revier an das sich die
riesenbagger schon weit herangefressen
haben seit heute wissen sie lützerath
sollweichen wegen des ukrainekriegs
werde die Kohle unter dem Dorf gebraucht
verkündet ausgerechnet eine grüne
das bedeutet lützerath muss bergbaulich
in Anspruch genommen werden also
abgebaggert werden wir erhalten dafür
eine politische Verständigung 8 Jahre
früher aus der Kohle auszusteigen
Kohleausstieg 2030 vereinbart mit RWE
die Grünen Spitze müht sich diese
Botschaft zu betonen lützerath werde
abgebaggert aber dafür blieben eben auch
280 Millionen Tonnen Braunkohle in der
Erde die Mengen an CO2-Emissionen die
jetzt im Boden gebunden bleiben sind
doch erheblich es ist ein guter Tag für
den Klimaschutz ich hoffe dass das auch
von der Klima- und Umweltbewegung so
gesehen und am Ende jedenfalls
weitgehend akzeptiert wird
2018 wurde im Rheinischen Revier um den
Hambacher Forst gerungen wochenlang mit
starken Polizeieinsatz und vielen
tausend Demonstrierenden damals waren
die Grünen stets an der Seite der
Umweltbewegung damals regierten sie
allerdings noch nicht mit entweder im
Land noch im Bund nun rumort ist heftig
in der eigenen Partei und bei den
umweltleuten erstmal ist es richtig den
Kohleausstieg vorzuziehen nach unserer
Einschätzung ist es aber auch so dass es
ausreichend Kohle gibt ohne weitere
Dörfer zu gefährden werden als Grüne
Jugend Teil sein da vielfältigen
Proteste für den Erhalt von lützerath
und werden bis das dorffeld alles dafür
geben das ist dann doch noch vielleicht
erhalten wird wir sagen hier ganz
deutlich wir haben nicht aufgegeben wir
kämpfen für die 1,5 Grad Grenze und wenn
das die Grünen nicht mehr machen wollen
ferienhaft wir sind da die Räumung des
Protestcamps in Lutzerath könnte
unmittelbar bevorstehen die
rodungsperiode dauert von Oktober bis
März was geschieht wenn die Bagger
kommen RWE appelliert an die
Protestierenden
was vor Ort passiert ist schwer
vorhersehbar Protest ist akzeptabel
Kritik ist in Ordnung aber es sollte in
jedem Fall immer friedlich und nach
rechtsstaatlichen Grundsätzen ablaufen
zwei Braunkohlekraftwerke sollen zudem
noch bis Frühjahr 2024 laufen auch das
ist Teil der Vereinbarung wie gut diese
Vereinbarung ist wie groß die Wut wird
im Rheinischen Revier blickt man
gespannt auf diesen Herbst
und mit dem Thema schauen wir auch an
die Börse zu sina-meinitz was bedeutet
das alles für RWE und für die
Beschäftigten ja RWE wandelt sich das
haben wir auch eben gesehen war der
Energieversorger einst bekannt als Atome
und kohlekonzern stand somit also nicht
gerade für saubere Energie ein wird nun
radikal umgebaut doch dieser Kurswechsel
geht auch mit Stellenstreichungen einher
bis zum Jahr 2030 sollen 5.500
Arbeitsplätze in der Braunkohle
wegfallen zunächst müssten hunderte die
sie schon auf den Vorruhestand
eingerichtet hätten länger arbeiten
anschließend werde der Stellenabbau dann
umso schneller vorangetrieben heißt es
ziel ist es grüner nachhaltiger und
effizienter zu werden rWE will nun neue
wasserstofffähige Kraftwerke bauen und
zudem bis zum Jahre 2030 weltweit mehr
als 50 Milliarden Euro in den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren investieren 15 Milliarden
hiervon sind für Deutschland vorgesehen
die Investition in erneuerbare Energien
bekommt im Aktienkurs gut rwe-papiere
legen heute 3% dazu der Energieversorger
also mit satten Gewinnen der DAX hatte
noch mehr Energie heute und kann dieses
Plus sogar noch toppen der Start in den
Oktober ist geglückt fast 3,8 Prozent
liegt das Börsenbarometer heute zu am
Ende dann ein Stand von
12.670 Punkten ja nach herben Verlust
nach Aktienmarkt Ende September nun
dieser Lichtblick Anleger hoffen dass
die Zentralbanken ihre Leitzinsen doch
nicht so stark anheben wie ursprünglich
angenommen denn das wiederum wirkt die
Konjunktur ab Sina meinitz vielen Dank
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball Champions
League von heute abend bayern München
hat gegen Viktoria Pilsen 5 zu 0
gewonnen
das Europaparlament hat mit großer
Mehrheit für einen einheitlichen
Standard bei Ladekabeln gestimmt die
neue Verordnung verpflichtet Hersteller
ab Ende 2024 etwa Mobiltelefone
Digitalkameras und Tablets mit einem
usb-c Stecker auszustatten laut EU
sollen so über 1000 Tonnen
Elektroschrott jährlich eingespart und
die Kosten für Verbraucher gesenkt
werden
einen gigantischen Hingucker gibt es ab
heute östlich von Berlin dort ist eine
Art schiffsfahrstuhl eingeweiht worden
mit dem neuen Schiffshebewerk im oder
Havelkanal können auch größere Frachter
einen Höhenunterschied von 36 Metern
überwinden es verkürzt so für
Containerschiffe den Weg aus Deutschland
nach Polen und funktioniert auch
unabhängig vom niedrigen Wasserstand auf
der oder der immer wieder den
Schiffsverkehr auf dem
deutsch-polnischen Grenzfluss lahmgelegt
hat die Baukosten betrugen 520 Millionen
Euro
das war's von uns weiter geht's gleich
mit der Anstalt um 0 Uhr 20 meldet sich
dann da sein könnte mir mit unserem
heute-update und uns gibt es morgen
wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter sehr warme Luft
erreicht uns aus dem Südwesten Europas
von Spanien über Frankreich bis nach
Deutschland kommt diese warme Luft und
so werden dann im Südwesten am Oberrhein
bis zu 25 Grad erreicht aber auch eine
Kaltfront spielt morgen eine Rolle dann
zum späten Nachmittag und abends mit
kompakten Wolken und vor allem im
Nordwesten kann es dann etwas regnen in
der Nacht bleibt es trocken im Norden
gibt es viele Wolken nach Süden in
klartis auf und in Gewässer Nähe also
ein Flüssen und sehen da bildet sich der
Nebel und der kann auch ziemlich dicht
sein bei tiefsten Temperaturen von zwei
bis fünf Grad im Südosten Deutschlands
und 14 Grad an der Nordsee morgen dann
nach Auflösung von lokalen Nebelfeldern
für Sonnenschein vor allem im Westen und
in der Mitte Richtung Donau oder Autos
am längsten und auch im Süden scheint
häufig die Sonne sonst im Nordwesten
verdichten sich die Wolken mit der
annähernden Kaltfront und dazu gibt es
viel Wind vor allem an der Nordsee und
in höheren Lagen da kriegt man das am
ehesten zu spüren Temperaturen bis 25
Grad ein Sommertag im Südwesten
Deutschlands sonst 18 Grad ganz im
Norden zum Beispiel ja und die nächsten
Tage gehen weiter nach Nebelauflösung
mit Sonnenschein bei 16 bis 22 Grad am
Donnerstag am Freitag ähnliche
Temperaturen noch trocken und am Samstag
kommen wieder schaue auf vor allem im
Norden und im Süden damit ein schöner
Abend